hey everybody welcome to reality check
now as we all know video games
frequently come under a lot of flack and
mainstream media for a variety of
reasons be it concerns over violent
content worries about their addictive
nature or gates anyway this episode is
not about any of that in fact I think
it's high time for some good news
positive video games stories so come
with me on this week's reality check as
we explore the latest cutting-edge
scientific research demonstrating that
playing video games can actually be good
for you
wonderful
do you remember when you learn to type
on a keyboard or perhaps to ride a bike
well a friend of mine who will remain
nameless actually managed to fail to
learn to ride a bike
twice pretty special huh
well you know what might have actually
helped her is playing more action video
games
you see tasks like typing and bike
riding which involve learning a new
pattern or coordination between your
vision and motor functions like moving
your arms and legs require what's called
sensory motor skills now a study led by
University of Toronto psychology
researchers found the people who play
action video games seem to be able to
learn new sensory motor skills more
quickly than non-gamers the experiment
carried out by the team involved two
groups one made up of 18 gamers who
regularly played first-person shooter
games and the other 18 non gamers who
had played little-to-no video games in
the past two years now to test
everyone's sensory motor skills they
didn't just chuck them all on bikes
because most normal people already know
how to do that no instead they had
everyone performed something called a
manual tracking task basically this
involved trying to keep a small green
square cursor at the center of a white
square moving target which dashed about
in a complicated but repeating pattern
now at the beginning there was pretty
much no difference between the gamers
and the non gamers they both picked up
the task initially at about the same
rate however by the close of the
experiment while everyone had improved
with time the gamers remarkably better
by the end according to the researchers
this is likely due to the gamers
superior ability in learning a novel
sensory motor pattern that is their
gaming experience enabled them to learn
better than the non gamers pretty
interesting stuff however the research
team weren't done just yet they had to
be sure that this improvement in the
gamers was down to learning the exact
task not just say because they were
better at controlling the mouse for
example so they repeated the experiment
but this time the pattern of movement of
the white target square was random and
didn't repeat this removed the
possibility of anyone learning the route
and lo and behold this time around
there was no difference between the
gamers and the non gamers
now when I was a little kid I played a
lot of Civilization with my dad and big
brother as well as being a hell of a lot
of fun this also gave me impeccable
knowledge of ancient capital cities that
an Sun Tzu's Art of War
well it turns out it's not just fact
learning the videogames can impart on
children in fact a recent study is
thrown up compelling evidence that young
people who play games can actually get a
boost in their overall English language
skills the study carried out to the
University of Gothenburg involved 76
young people aged 10 and 11 and
demonstrated that young gamers really
gain an advantage in terms of their
English vocabulary over the non gaming
contemporaries the key it seems to a
massing of voluminous lexicon is
elementally a consequence of periodic
exposure to novel prose in other words
it's not a function of the gameplay as
such it's all about being exposed to
more written and spoken English outside
of school and games are a very effective
way to do this massively multiplayer
online role-playing games
we're actually called out as being
particularly effective due to the large
numbers of real people all interacting
with one another in a virtual world as
associate professor lists Kirsten salvan
explained as a player you simply have to
be able to understand what's being said
to read English and to interact yourself
by both writing and speaking English
at the beginning of this episode we saw
some of the merits of playing action
titles but now it's a turn of puzzle
games these have been shown to improve
our overall mental flexibility and also
executive functions so what does that
mean
well it's basically our ability to think
on our feet to quickly problem-solve and
deal with sudden changes in the
environment the game used in the study
was none other than super popular mobile
puzzler cut the rope and the research
demonstrated that it took as little as
an hour a day of gaming to get the
improvements so how exactly did the
study work well a group of non-gamers
played for an hour a day five days a
week for four weeks the participants
were split into four groups each one
playing in different game once the four
weeks of gaming were over all test
subjects then took part in a number of
tests the results showed that players
have cut the rope could switch between
tasks 33% faster were 30% faster in
adapting to new situations and 60%
better in blocking out distractions and
focusing on the tasks at hand than
before training so how could games like
Cut the Rope actually help with this
well it's possibly to do with the fact
that games like Cut the Rope constantly
require you to employ new strategies in
order to progress a tactics and tricks
that you learn at the start probably
won't help you later on so you need to
be able to think creatively
according to assistant professor Michael
D Patterson this finding is important
because previously no video games have
demonstrated this type of broad
improvement to executive functions which
are important for general intelligence
dealing with these situations and
managing multitasking so what do you
make of this week's episode have you
ever observed any of these effects in
real life and can you think of any other
ways that video games might actually be
good for us let me know in the comments
down below or you can get in touch with
me directly over twitter at cam for
Ezreal and remember that's the place if
you want to suggest to me any potential
topics for reality
okay thanks for watching guys see you
next week